are incredibly proud to announce the new  films for phase 58. we're beginning next  year with a movie that everyone likes  but no one really loves next we will  have over 300 disney plus tv shows only  one of which will be actually important  for the larger universe then in the  summer we're releasing a newly acquired  property that's only ever seen horrible  adaptations so anything better than dog  [ __ ] will satisfy all of you the next  movie even the die hard comics fans are  a little confused as to why we're making  it but uh  we're doing it anyways so then in the  winter we're releasing a sequel to one  of our better movies so yeah you can go  ahead and clap yeah that's fine you have  been patient and i want to give you all  something really special so by the end  of phase 58 we're releasing not only one  but two movies where actual important  stuff happens you only have to wait 50  more years